next on book TV the main enemy it's the
new book from Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist James risin and milk Bearden
who headed up the CIA's Eastern European
division as the Soviet Union was coming
undone this talk from the Woodrow Wilson
Center in Washington DC is about an hour
and a half as a clearinghouse for newly
declassified historical records and
recent international history we also
tried to provide a forum in the heart of
Washington for the discussion of new
important and relevant historical
findings and publications such as the
main enemy the inside story of the CIA's
final showdown with the KGB which we're
going to talk about today last year the
project sponsored a major critical
international history conference on the
war in Afghanistan 1979 to 1989 there
are conference reports outside and mill
Bearden previewed a few of the
revelations at the conference and it is
with great pleasure that we welcome him
back here to the center let me introduce
him and our other speakers briefly and
then proceed with the presentation Milt
Bearden is retired from the Central
Intelligence Agency in 1990 since 1994
after 30 years in the CIA's clandestine
services he rose through the ranks to
become one of the CIA's most senior
officers and one of the most highly
decorated operations officers in its
senior service mr. Burdon is the author
of the black tulip a novel of war in
Afghanistan and the frequent contributor
to the abet pages of the New York Times
and other major newspapers for service
in the CIA mr. Bearden was awarded the
agency's highest decoration the
distinguished intelligence Medal as well
as other commendations and awards his
for James reason I'm welcome as well
warmly to the Wilson Center to his left
is a Pulitzer prize-winning journalist
with the New York Times he's based in
the papers washington boro he was
co-winner as mention of the Pulitzer
Prize in 2002 for explanatory reporting
for coverage of September 11 and
terrorism he's the author of ralph of
angels the American abortion war in
published in 1998 he joined the New York
Times in Washington in that year in 1998
previously worked at the Los Angeles
Times covering business economics and
national security affairs welcome we are
we have the great fortune an honor to
have two distinguished commentators with
us today ambassador raymond garter and
ambassador Robert Oakley let me
introduce them briefly now ambassador
guard have served as ambassador to
Bulgaria and former deputy director of
the Bureau of political military affairs
at the Department of State
he was also executive officer and senior
advisor to the US Department of State
allegation to the salt one and ABM
Treaty negotiations from 69 to 73 he has
published an enormous number of books on
Cold War history and international
relations
too many to name them all now but yet
let me just mention a few the great
transition American Soviet relations and
the end of the Cold War in 1994
deterrent and confrontation American
Soviet relations from Nixon to Reagan in
1984 19 and republished in 1994 and
reflections on the Cuban Missile Crisis
published in 1987 ambassador Gaurav has
also published numerous articles and
journals and mass media and is currently
a guest scholar at the Brookings
Institution in Washington DC and also a
frequent contributor and co-conspirator
with the Cold War international history
project ambassador Oakley
in 1991 as ambassador to Pakistan his 34
years in the foreign service included
tours as ambassador to Somalia and so a
year coordinator for counterterrorism
and twice the National Security Council
Senior Director for the Near East and
South Asia Ambassador Oakley is
currently is a distinguished fellow at
the National Defense University in
Washington DC one welcome to both of you
and now without further ado I'll turn it
over to the co-authors then to our
commentators all of them will be fairly
brief so that we can quickly open up the
floor to questions and comments I think
thank you very much for not only hosting
this book launch but for the tremendous
work that the center has done which
provided us a invaluable insight into
key elements on the timeline of look we
we wrote that in particular the the
Afghan drama I think that the
information that came out on Christians
conference on the Afghan war was
probably the most complete accounting of
what was going on in the Kremlin leading
up to the war and particularly after
Gorbachev came to power and started
jockeying for position to get out of
that war it fit into our timeline where
we developed not only the American side
in Afghanistan in Pakistan
but certainly the Soviet side as well
and also many thanks to Nancy Meyers who
has pulled this marvelous event together
so thanks to you to both of you into the
center Jim Rison and I started talking
about this project
in 1998 when I was just finishing up my
novel the black tulip and looking to the
future and other literary efforts and we
talked about it for the next couple of
years until we finally decided to take
it to the gentler Nesbit agency which is
my agent in New York and then to Random
House and began work on this a little
over three years ago
the concept was pretty straightforward
if I tried to write this alone I could
probably do most of it but you would
never really understand if you can
believe it all you could say mmmm but
that's a puff piece by some CIA guy and
what do we know if Jim wanted to write
the whole story himself he could
probably do that too but then you'd say
but what does he know guys that aren't
inside don't know really what was going
on there so we decided to do this
together and it is essentially an oral
history of the events that occurred
around in between the KGB and the CIA
from the year of the spy 1985 until
those Red Army Troopers went out on the
Kremlin wall at Christmastime 1991 and
hauled down the hammer and sickle for
the last time and then hoisted up the
Russian tricolor we have interviewed
dozens of people for hundreds of hours
on both sides of the issue we have
developed access to I think some of the
most remarkable Russian formerly Soviet
formerly KGB personalities who sat down
and walked through this thing and said
well here's how we saw it on the other
side of the line where you were and that
will be the thread that will kind of
move from part one of the book which
is the year of the spy the 1985 troubles
at CIA when everybody that we were
running in Moscow started dying through
the Afghan period which was for me and
for this book is 1986 to 89 until
general Boris groom off walked across
the Oxus River and declared victory and
then we pick up for the end game of the
Soviet Union until it all goes down in
1991 and we will introduce you to two
very senior KGB officers some who were
chasing the spies that were working for
us and some who were the spies that they
didn't kill some who were caught in the
middle of that game and then carry you
all the way through to the end and what
we we fervently hope is a gripping yarn
that probably could only be told in this
fashion with it with the two of us
working together on this thing it is an
oral history
it's the chances of it ever getting
written diminish as we all had one year
to our lives and there will never be an
opening of the files on all of this
stuff a word about publication
pre-publication review I faithfully
submit everything I write to the CIA
they picked away at little things that
they they felt strongly about it didn't
detract from anything we were trying to
say my goal is not to my goal in writing
anything whether it's an op-ed piece or
or a novel or nonfiction is to keep two
things in mind about my CIA career and
that is one do no harm
don't put anybody at risk you can't do
that anyway that's not right it's
immoral and second don't do anything
that makes it harder for the very fine
men and women we're still out there
trying to slug away into a job and pRb
the publication a pre-publication review
board they
they have more stringent rules than that
but but they all boil down to that Jim
didn't submit any of his materials to
prb because it's that would be madness
but we didn't use this book as a means
of saying okay Jimbo you go do that I'll
do this there wasn't there wasn't an
effort to do a bait-and-switch and we
didn't do a bait-and-switch
and I think Jem is a good American saw
that he would stick to those same basic
two rules that do no harm and don't make
it too much harder and in the end we can
still tell one heck of a yarn so that's
where we are
after the commentator's I'd like to get
open it up but I'll pass it over to Jim
at this moment and lean back and listen
to my co-author who after three years
and being one year delayed in getting
this to our publisher that was bad
enough but we had publishers in France
that were just going nuts and other
countries beginning to wanna back out of
a contract so we were late it's out we
think it's a terrific book but we wrote
it we're gonna have to hear from you
thanks thanks again to the Cold War
history project for all the work that
they've done and as Milt said they were
invaluable in in helping us we used a
lot of their materials and I use them
particularly on the 1989 and the
communications that were going back and
forth between Moscow and Eastern Europe
I thought I'd start by talking a little
bit about the first part of our book
which is what we call the year of the
spy which as many of you know was the
nickname for 1985 which looking back was
probably the high-water mark of Cold War
the Cold War espionage wars it was the
year in which probably more there were
more arrests more more publicity for
spying at probably any time since the
McCarthy
era in the United States certainly and I
think if you look back it's now at the
time it all looked kind of random and it
looked it was hard to figure out why all
these things were happening all at once
but I think it there is actually some
rhyme and reason to why 1985 became this
year when there were so many arrests so
many spiders and also so many new
recruited spies people like Aldrich Ames
and Robert Hansen who we didn't know
about in 1985 but who were beginning
their espionage careers at that time and
I think what you have to do to
understand why there was this high
watermark of espionage is you have to
look back at the history of the CIA and
the KGB maybe go back to the 50s and 60s
to understand what had happened there
was like a cycle it was almost like an
El Nino effect there had been this long
period at the CIA going back to the 60s
and the angleton iran james jesus
angleton had been in charge of
counterintelligence at the CIA in the
60s and really had created an atmosphere
at the agency in which there was a
paralysis largely in Soviet operations
he had come to believe thanks in part to
one notorious Soviet defector named
Anatoly Golitsyn that there was a inner
and inner KGB and an outer KGB and that
the see all the KGB officers who were
trying to defect to the west in the 60s
were part of a massive disinformation
campaign mounted by this inner KGB to
deceive the United States and the CIA
and so there was a sense throughout that
he propagated and others around him
propagated that no one from the KGB who
tried to volunteer to the CIA could be
trusted that culture that atmosphere
pervaded the culture and began to make
it very difficult
for younger CIA officers in the 60s and
early 70s to try to recruit KGB officers
anyone who was seen as trying to promote
the idea that someone who had come to
them was a valid spy who wanted to work
for the United States they themselves
then came under suspicion and so quickly
the word spread throughout the agency I
think that it was not career enhancing
to try to recruit a KGB officer and so
by the early 70s this culture had had
really taken hold in it was it finally
was dispelled when a man named David Lee
took over at the Soviet head of the
Soviet operations in the Directorate of
operations and began to try and really
eliminate or reduce the influence that
Angleton had held over the way in which
the CIA had handled Soviet spies by the
mid seventies the new openness that
Blier and others tried to provide to
Soviet operations began to bear fruit
they really reopened a number of lines
to soviets who had tried to volunteer
prior to that they began to become more
aggressive in their recruitment efforts
and they slowly over time by the late
1970s the CIA had developed a number of
recruitments and had a number of
volunteers so that the CI for the first
time really had an extensive spy network
inside the Soviet Union and inside the
KGB in the GRU there had always of
course been some spies but this was by
far far and away much larger network
than they'd ever had one reason that the
timing was was was propitious for Blee
and the CIA in the mid-1970s was that
you had a new generation of KGB officers
people who were no long been born after
the war who no longer felt the same
way about the Soviet Union and were
beginning to see through the propaganda
and and the there was beginning to see
through the Soviet system
they were looking they were more
interested in a better life in the West
and they were less fearful of their
systems of the possibility of getting
caught and so this was the CIA came up
the Soviet division actually came up
with a phrase the new Soviet man who
they thought would be more susceptible
to recruitment and that was that idea
took hold around the the world inside
the CIA and it actually turned out to be
true they they were beginning to get
Soviets who were more and more cynical
and more and more skeptical of their
system and so the to the the to fact the
factors the the growth of of the
skepticism and cynicism within the ranks
of the KGB and a new openness of the CIA
began to bear fruit on the other side I
think by the late 70s and early 80s
there was a cynicism in the United
States as well and a growing belief
among some people in the United States
that the Cold War was a game and that I
think was a real important change within
the military and and the intelligence
community and you began to get people
who felt that they it was it wouldn't
really harm America if you spied for the
Russians and made a little money out of
it and so you began to get more and more
Americans willing to spy for the United
for the Soviet Union there was less of
the kind of fear that had taken place in
the 1950s at the time of the McCarthy
era and after Vietnam I think there was
a growing cynicism that led some of
these people to try and make some money
off of the national security information
they had so I think by the mid 80s you
had suddenly for the first time you had
a lot of spies rummaging around through
the closets of both countries and I
think they began to bump into each other
and all of these spies began to find out
about
each other and when they did they began
to trigger espionage investigations on
both sides and I think that was one of
the reasons you had this sudden flare-up
in 1985 was that you you saw people like
John Walker who had been spying for a
long time suddenly suddenly arrested in
Aldrich Ames who was about who was just
beginning to spy at that point saw when
Walker got arrested that he was
convinced for instance that Walker had
been betrayed by one of the KGB officers
working for the CIA and Ames knew as
chief of counterintelligence in the
Soviet division how many KGB officers
were working for the CIA and he didn't
believe the cover story or he thought
that the the idea that Walker's wife had
turned him in was a cover story and so
he then a month after Walker's arrest on
his next meeting with the cage with the
Soviets handed over a list of all of the
so of the KGB officers and other Soviets
working for the CIA thinking that that
way he could eliminate anyone who might
have any information about him from
telling either the CIA or the FBI about
his espionage that triggered a massive
investigation inside the key the KGB and
led to a series of executions the
problem then became as the CIA tried to
understand what was happening they had
other spies beginning to spy for the
Soviets and it made it the layers of
espionage made it very difficult to pet
to figure out and sort out who was doing
what you had Edward Lee Howard who had
been fired from the CIA in 1983 began to
spy for the Soviets in 1984 at first
when he was discovered see I thought
well that answers that question
but what they didn't understand was that
he had he and Ames overlapped and then
you had Robert Hansen who was spying at
almost this at the same time and
betraying many of the same people that
Ames had betrayed and so you had it was
very difficult to sort out the layers of
espionage until many years later
that's not to excuse the way in which
the investigation was was mishandled
within the CIA in fact they the agency
for many years failed to conduct an
aggressive investigation of these these
matters but it does help understand why
it was so difficult when you had so many
different spies operating at the same
time it began became harder and harder
to focus on which one knew which thing
and to narrow down the list of suspects
well we melt and I have have determined
going back over 1985 is something I
think is pretty interesting is that even
with today with all of the spies that we
now know about we don't think that they
can be accounted they can be held
accountable for all of the betrayals
that happened to American intelligence
in the year of the spy we think there is
three possibly four cases that really
neither Edward Lee Howard Robert Hansen
or Aldrich Ames can be held accountable
for the timing doesn't quite work the
and the the places and access doesn't
quite seem to fit and when Milton I was
interesting when we began to look at
this and kind of talk to people about it
and we puzzled through this and we saw
that there were these cases that that
the timing just doesn't work for any of
these people we began to ask people in
the intelligence community is this right
and I think they were kind of surprised
and they admitted yes this is what
they've been thinking themselves for
many years it's difficult for us on the
outside to tell how active the
investigation is into the possibility of
a fourth mole but clearly there is there
are people in senior positions and
counterintelligence in the US government
who now believe that they didn't catch
all of the spies in the 1985 period the
it's it's unclear whether that person or
persons would be at the CIA or the FBI
or somewhere else in the government but
Milt and I if if he wants to jump in
here we could kind of run through
brief very briefly the four cases that
we think may have and may not be
accounted for by Ames Howard and Hansen
or any other known spies the one one
comment that after we finished the
project and we're looking back through
that that cloud of Hansen Ames and
Howard and and have can reach the
conclusion that there was a fourth man
we reached another conclusion as well
our everybody's colleague Oleg Kalugin
here in Washington still wrote a book
called the first Directorate and in
there he has stated that the end of the
Cold War it was a rout CIA had just not
only put the KGB up against the ropes
but it just routed them in the in the
final in game well that was that was a
little premature I think that in the end
of this engagement with the KGB it
looked a whole lot more like the second
ali-frazier fight in Manila to where we
still you're not sure because I think
that the the mole hunts go on but to get
down to something that we have in here
is that the period in 1982-83 up until
June of 1985 when Ames went in with that
list that included everybody also have
three probably four compromises of
Soviet KGB officers who were working for
either the American intelligence British
intelligence or French intelligence and
they were not only compromised and
brought home or recalled home under
elaborate ruses very well thought out
very documented ly elaborate ruses by
the KGB and subsequently executed or in
the case of one Sergei bohon the GRU
officer was able to smell something was
up and called his emergency meeting with
his CIA officers in Athens and now lives
or in the u.s. the French agent was
arrested an elaborate story about
involving a murderer and then allegedly
compromised himself while in prison and
then was rewritten and then executed
another KGB officer was sent off to
Africa and then called back home through
an elaborate ruse where he was to be to
come home and his father had had the
good fortune of finding a flat very near
him in Moscow and so he rushed him to
buy that and was arrested in Moscow in
another very questionable situation
the KGB maned maintained the most
elaborate chess game of a cover the set
of cover stories to keep us confused
about what happened to these people and
when that the only conclusion you really
can reach is that they were betrayed
before the June 1985 they in fact were
were the treated with great great care
by the KGB in trying to conceal that
they had how they had been betrayed and
whoever betrayed them is just still out
there it could be dead or or but not
accounted for and that is the whole
concept of the fourth man there is
another case that we throw out there
that most of you might have read about
Oleg Gordievsky who is alive and well in
the UK and we'll put him in that group
but I myself think that they had that he
may have had the seeds of his own
destruction and in fact got himself into
trouble but we put him in there and
would let you decide or let others
decide or use it as a bookmark for some
point later when there's more
information on all this or when we pick
up the paper and find it we indeed
indeed did find the fourth man let me
wanted to say one thing interesting
about the Gordievsky case which is one
of the great ironies
trying to sort this whole period out it
shows you how confusing it can be in
early in late 1984 the CIA Soviet
division had concluded that the British
had a mole inside the KGB and the
British weren't telling them who it was
Burton Gerber then the chief of the
Soviet division of the CIA assigned the
task of finding out who was the this the
mole in Britain - a senior member of his
staff named Aldrich Ames and Aldrich
Ames in about January 1985 figured out
that it was what none other than Oleg
Gordievsky and it turned out I think
through other means the CIA was able to
confirm that it we still don't think
that it was Ames who betrayed Gordievsky
however because the timing doesn't work
at the time Ames was investigating that
he had not yet started spying for the
Soviets he didn't turn over his
information on Gordievsky until June
1985 and by that time it's clear that
Gordievsky had already been compromised
so it's one of these it shows you how
sometimes difficult it is to figure out
exactly who shot who in some of these
situations the the final statement on
that whole fourth man's story is that
it's reminiscent of the Cambridge five
and it it took it took how long for the
British finally to unmask the fifth man
which was decades it was Anthony Sir
Anthony blunt who was had been knighted
by the Queen in the in the interim
so obviously this story will go on
somebody in Russia well at some point I
think decide that there's more value in
dropping a diamond on the fourth man and
somebody will pass that along and
and we'll all learn about it I certainly
hope this nobody in this room one of the
one of them one last point is that we
did find also that in almost every case
a spy is betrayed by another spy in the
aims in as we all know that Robert
Hanssen was betrayed by a Russian spy
what we also found out is that alder
James was betrayed in part by another
another Russian spy who has never been
identified and that I think was
something that the CI has never
acknowledged prior to this thank you
people familiar with the cold war
project know that book launches at the
project and ever just laboratory events
but we hope the beginning of a critical
debate of the issues raised in the main
enemy and so again I'm delighted to have
two experts here today as commentators
to begin the discussion of the book and
let me turn it over to ambassador
guardhouse thank you this is a great
book I think it's really a very very
interesting book well informed well
written and and makes an important
contribution to our better understanding
of the role of intelligence in the Cold
War and in general to the unfolding of
this important period this important
chapter in an ongoing contest between
the intelligence agencies of the East
and West during the Cold War it is a
testimony to the fact that the
intelligence war was to a large extent
indeed a contest between intelligence
and counterintelligence of the two sides
most of the secrets that were leaked
most of the people involved were
intelligence agents on the two sides
this is not to say that intelligence was
not also in some respects important with
respect to other aspects of information
and action that were of that were
relevant to the policy process and more
in more than in the policy process to
military planning on the two sides as
examples in the book indicate for
example although they're not discussed
it's it really is another subject there
were key people involved who did provide
important information on the military
plans and capabilities and operations of
the two sides tolkachev and a couple
other of the soviet agents for example
in supplying important information on
soviet aviation and the radar and other
activities to the United States the
probably most important from the
American side in this respect was Walker
or the Walker ring in what was provided
in the period leading up to this about
US Navy codes and operations and and so
forth but but again to a very
considerable extent at least it was an
espionage and counter espionage war
between the agencies of intelligence on
the two sides the book as the authors
have have indicated was their intention
and indeed it's well carried through
does help to give a feel for the
interaction of the two sides by looking
at this not just as many books do as
American intelligence operations on the
one hand or Soviet intelligence
operations on the other of course it's
always interactive but
the the the nature and the extent of the
of the the process and the breadth of
the process of interaction is very well
conveyed through the story as it's told
here one by the way one small or rather
one very specific example of a kind of
collaboration that is has not been known
much before and is referred to here in
fact more precisely and in and certainly
more in greater detail authoritative lis
something called the Gov real official
established between CIA and the KGB as
early as 1983 and occasionally used for
informal discussions between the two
where there might be a common interest
in letting the other side know about
some aspect of developments that it was
in our interests that say that that they
should have a better picture or
vice-versa there is less new on the
1985-86 period although it is a very
good and useful review and important to
the story here and brings together much
of the material that's appeared
in a number of other places as well as
some new and the long shadow of the
outcome particularly of the disastrous
decimation of of American agents that is
Soviets working for the United States in
in that period and I say the shadow of
that goes on through including what I
find convincing and the whole argument
and discussion that's just being
presented about an undiscovered fourth
man in somewhere in American
intelligence or counterintelligence
service during this period it is it also
gives insight into the workings of both
CIA in particular and to some extent the
KGB it is well as I've already mentioned
it it makes in general important
contributions the history of
intelligence in the Cold War as let me
back up for a moment just as to say in
the interest of full disclosure that I
worked at the Central Intelligence
Agency at an earlier period in the 1950s
until I went to the State Department in
1961 and I still had some continuing
relationship although it was a bona fide
it transferred to the Foreign Service in
1961 and then in the Department of State
until I retired at the end of 1979 but
I'm that's mentioning his background to
get out of the way and say that I'm
addressing this and commenting of course
in terms of my more recent career as a
diplomatic historian from that
standpoint it is it is valuable to have
this source the only criticism that I
have to make of the book is one that is
specialized and limited one and that is
that there are from the standpoint of
its use by historian some limitations
because there are no footnotes that's
not so important because those elements
that could have been readily footnoted
also are well enough known to historians
that is for example quotations from
Politburo discussions in the night in
the 1980s which we now have thanks as
has already been indicated by the
authors two works of the Cold War
international history project and
National Security Archive and others it
is it is has been a very successful
venture I think between the co-authors
and I think it's it's been very very
well done it is difficult however to
know of course in fact one can't really
always know what contribution each of
the two authors has made and from that
standpoint one must say that in part it
is a first-hand account and in part it
is an in well considered and well
researched secondhand account of
different aspects of this but you can't
always tell which is which particularly
because even those portions that the mr.
Rison has written which relate to mr.
Burton's
own role are also are given we are told
in the first person now this is just I
stated in a brief statement about
sources but it does make it a little
difficult to to know as I said what is
first hand and what is I will done
second hand contribution in some at
least in some parts of the book but
again I think it is a very fine book it
is it is authoritative within the bounds
that it could be it is a darn good read
- thank you very much ray ambassador
Oakley I've always been awed by dr. cart
off scholarship and I'm no scholar but
I'm amused at the last point you made
about the difficulty sometimes of
distinguishing between which author
wrote what I think that they've done
that on purpose we have a Hall of
Mirrors here just as you see the
labyrinth between which CIA agents and
KGB agents are participating in
maneuvering we have fourth men I mean
this really doesn't belong in this spy
museum but it certainly you belong right
up there with john lecarre a it seems to
me it's a superb piece of writing you
have a very gripping tale Milt you've
all have done that very nicely I'm
impressed by the way in which Milton
recruited agents or Jim has developed
sources whichever way you want to talk
about it in terms of getting KGB
insights in the first hand in addition
to the scholarship which exists you've
gotten people to talk which is the most
important thing of all and I think that
really adds a huge amount to the book
whether you're talking about the spies
were you talking about Afghanistan Milt
the fact that you've been able to get
the other viewpoint how they saw the
main enemy I think is extremely
important and it contributes a great
deal it seems to me to the liveliness
and the gripping this of the tale but
also to the value of it for scholars
my association with milk was going to
use the station chief in Pakistan
fighting the war and I was the
ambassador I came in you right after the
plane crashed carrying pregnancy and
Akhtar who'd been the two principal
people Pakistan behind the war in
Afghanistan against the Soviets and
whilst that's a good job putting that
perspective I would like milk if you all
had a chance to write a second book to
develop the impact of the war in
Afghanistan and the crushing loss which
the Soviets suffered upon the Soviet
Union Soviet empire because it seems to
me that's easier to measure it's hard
for me to understand the impact of the
spy game upon the way in which Soviet
Union eventually crumbled but it's clear
to see the impact of Afghanistan to me
it was truly a seminal event even
greater impact upon Soviet Union than
Vietnam had upon us in so many different
ways in terms of the culture in terms of
willingness to adventure in so many
different ways the impact of the war in
Afghanistan collapsed the Soviet empire
the discrediting of communism whole
works and Milt brings that out he brings
it up not to the point of assessing it
but at the point of showing the effect
it had which i think is very there I
like melt that you have just before you
took over the u.s. was lucky and we blew
up one of their ammunition depots in
Kabul we had the misfortune of by
accident blowing up one of our
ammunition depots in Pakistan which is
not the tribute to enemy action but
nevertheless this is a good scholarly
sequel to the black tulip and it's a
it's a very very well-done piece of work
and I'm in admiration of both of you
thanks Bob thank you much and Ray thank
you very much let me make this a couple
of quick comments
um actually right Bob Oakley's got it
right we really wanted it to be seamless
we wanted to be sure that you could
never be sure who's writing this book
the same was with the the footnotes the
only people who absolutely know who
wrote what are the publication Review
Board who reviewed every word I wrote
but not what what Jim rope we started
off with the idea of footnotes and
decide not let's don't do it let's just
make it be as good to read the kind of
the oral history thing and let it go and
let somebody else in the next cut do
that let me say one thing there is that
it's also difficult when we're dealing
with a number of former intelligence
officers who were talking to us without
the authorization of the CIA or the KGB
or the Russian government of the
American government and so we we didn't
want to list all our sources and that
was a that was a problem we realized we
would have to deal with but I thought it
was worth trying to do that thank you
thank you for the two insightful
commentaries let's move on to comments
and questions from the audience if you
could please identify yourself before
speaking and also wait until you've got
the microphone yes
Stuart Goldman from the Congressional
Research Service I like to follow up on
the first point Ray got off made and in
fact one or both of you to amplify a
little bit on what you believed were the
most consequential of outcomes of the
spy games on both sides to carry it
beyond the air war in the first world
war where one ace we should invent other
ways but you know what our contribute to
the big war effort I mean well I think
that was for me one of the most
difficult problems to deal with in
writing a book about this
I remember our editor in fact very early
on was pushing us as well what are what
is this what is the significance of
these spy games and spy Wars you know
what did the CIA really win the Cold War
or did the KGB stop the stop you know
slowed down the defeat of the Soviet
Union
what is the large policy and consequence
of espionage and I've never been able to
figure that out and if anybody else can
I'd love to hear this story I think it's
very difficult to quantify the national
security significance of any specific
espionage case with a very few
exceptions like Adolf tolkachev there
are cases that make a difference in the
technological advantages of one side or
the other but overall I think one of the
problems towards the end of the Cold War
was that intelligence officers on both
sides decided to spy for the other side
because they thought it was a game
Aldrich Ames certainly said that and I
believe that that's what he he felt and
so it's difficult in the end I think
that's one reason we tried not to make
these grand policy conclusions in the
book is that it's it's very difficult to
say what was the role of intelligence
counterintelligence in winning or losing
the Cold War and so what we tried to do
is just tell these stories and tell a
human as a human narrative as human as
possible
maybe milk has some other thought I
would I would
second everything Jim has said and they
make just a couple of other points the
cases we we tell about in this in this
book the main enemy are dead guys and
those are essentially the only ones we
can use the bulk of them are
intelligence officers I've struggled
with this thing as you look at each one
of those cases of a dead intelligence
officer inevitably the question is was
that worth it and and and I don't think
there's ever been a satisfactory answer
to that because the the Soviet
punishment was uniform it was it was
execution and but until the end of the
the game when I was in Moscow in
Lubyanka and a KGB general said to me he
said you know it's very interesting in
August of 1991 when all the world
Mikasa gave which was off in the Crimea
Boris's on the on the tank standing up
making his big talk
Vladimir couch coffee's with all those
other drunks they keep calling over to
the Lubyanka and out to the first chief
director and say we just send in your
paramilitary forces and do this and do
that and then I look on CNN here and I
see your president comes out in
Kennebunkport and he says who's failed
and I know that you have seven guys and
that we've just executed in the basement
here and I think maybe you have seven
more I think maybe you know more about
what's going on in his coup than we do
and so he said we all just signed out
and went to our - yes it was the only
time I ever heard anything that that
even perversely validated all the
intelligence officers that died in 1985
and 86 but I would also say that that
the casualties of any engagement when
looked at singly and tried and and one
tries to evaluates it is that dead kid
laying on Normandy Beach did he really
make a difference well it in the macro
sense yes but I struggled with that one
and I don't think either one of us have
answered your question which is really
the one was it all worth it
I think yeah my last thing is that the
one thing I come out of this with and
the whole experience of being against in
dealing with the Soviet Union that this
that the Soviet Union in fact was not
some noble experiment gone bad it was a
real real issue they had a lot of
rockets that would have gone down ranged
and they had a crazy idea that never
worked out and so we probably would have
to do it pretty much the same way if we
had to do it over again yeah I mean I
think you you need every major power
needs spies it needs an intelligence
service to find out about its
adversaries and that's it I guess that's
a different question from was you know
Vladimir you know should he have given
you that piece of information that led
to his execution as Milt said um doesn't
mean that intelligence doesn't play a
role in national security but it's it's
one of those things that I think we
tried to avoid preaching I think that's
the what we're trying to say and just
tell these stories and not try and draw
any grand policy conclusions ambassador
cartels or Oakley you like to respond or
Chuck Cogan a couple of observations in
September 1986 we had a station Chiefs
meeting in Frankfurt I was a cos Paris
at the time and we got a briefing by the
head of the Soviet division Gus Hathaway
and it was a very gripping briefing
because he said that there were certain
things happening to our KGB agents which
couldn't be explained by Edward Lee
Howard and I remember getting a very
sort of a weird sensation listening to
this and one of the possibilities
mentioned was they supposed to break
into this American Embassy in Moscow was
sergeant lonetree
so that's my first question whatever
became of the lonetree
what's the resolution of that second
question is Milton you mentioned a
French agent I presume this is the one
that called farewell farewell Clayton
lonetree
I was sitting at the same
you were in New York no station chief
conference I was a chief out in Pakistan
and I picked up my traffic that morning
and then Clayton lonetree had been
erased arrested there was another guy
another a marine guard called by the
name Bracy I said Wow that does it
because I knew Ames didn't answer the
questions nor did Howard and I had left
her for the Afghan program but then
after one looked at that at Lone Tree
and Bracy
that didn't work either so we were still
back to those problems
the French agent farewell wonderful
agent provided the entire list of what
the Soviets were trying to steal and
technology from the West he gave it to
the French and eighty to Francois meter
all gave you know gave it to us and gave
it to Ronald Reagan and so we knew about
via trough in 1982 and about as soon as
we learned about that the French had a
an SNT scientific and technical
collection officer he was arrested in
this elaborate thing and later then
executed a year and a half two years
later so that would unknown lonetree I
think the the legal case against
lonetree kind of dribbled off in a very
inconclusive way and no one publicly is
ever really I think come to grips with
with what happened in that case but what
we found was that the CIA did come to a
fairly conclusive belief that he had
nothing to do with with the losses they
were able to show that he never allowed
the KGB into the Moscow station in the
US Embassy in fact what we found and
reported I think has never been reported
before was that the CIA station had
cameras inside the station that were
filming around the clock and the CIA
checked all those cameras and never saw
any sign of either lonetree Bracy or the
be inside the station they also checked
the vault locks and seals those were
never broken in any way that looked like
a consistent pattern and to top that off
because because of all these losses that
had happened the CIA though sent
officers over to Moscow and took every
scrap of paper in every document out of
the Moscow station brought it back to
Washington and examined it and they
could never and then they checked to see
how much information about all of the
spies that they had already lost or were
known to have lost was in Moscow and
they concluded that well Moscow station
knew about a lot of the spies that had
already been arrested they didn't know
about all of them and so they began to
rule out the possibility that lone trio
Bracy had betrayed them
we also ran some traps against them you
know and by the end of 85 when we knew
we had a big problem we created two
Soviet agents that never were I went off
to Nairobi and in an elaborate set of
cables back recruited a a Soviet in
quotes who
we just thought was kind of an
interesting snot-nosed guy and we
thought well let's let's test it with
him and so I sent some cables back and
then we kind of just distributed that to
a very small listening and widen the
list to see if anything was going to
happen to this guy and yes yes we were
going to rush in and save him if he did
get hold off in Chains we also did the
same thing by sending somebody out to
Moscow to brief in our shielded
enclosure to brief the chief out there
on a new case on the chance that they
had been some technical penetration by
the KGB into our our office in Moscow I
remember I had gone out once before and
the station chief there had taken a
sheet of paper from his yellow pad while
we were in this super
secure location and then he wrote
something on it and shoved it over to me
and then I read it and it says sometimes
I think they're in here with me not
without a microphone so let me just add
the microphone but briefly material was
paid a visit later on by a soviet
scientific type who persuaded him that
helped persuade him that the Americans
had duped him and that's the way he
wound up feeling about farewell case he
would create it thank you
question over there Dave Rodgers
independent historian if I were James
did so much damage why did the Merrill
factors in the do who were responsible
for him getting away with it so why were
they not why were they not punished I
raised this question because I was there
working at the time and I can testify
that the morale does it was destroyed by
this failure to take any action and as
we all know it cost Jim Woolsey his job
thank you not almost like to throw that
one to John McGavin III it's always a
good ability accountable a good idea
accountability is a great idea but I
mean then I would suggest that you know
you were there working with Aldrich Ames
we should first start with you
No excuse me and we can't do this
without a microphone so if you yeah no I
I would suggest it probably there's no
answer because there's never any
satisfactory way to to come down and
manage the accountability issue let me
yeah let me just step in for a second I
think this is where I kind of tried to
become in our when writing the book kind
of the independent arbiter of some of
these issues
there was a as you can imagine a lot of
bitterness at the CIA after Ames his
arrest that still lingers in some
corners are of the American intelligence
community I think it was a very
difficult process because Ames had
gotten away with spying for so long
it was difficult to assign one
individual person who should be held
accountable it became a bloodbath inside
the CIA at the top levels reprimands
were handed out and I think a lot of
that bitterness led to an exodus of a
lot of people from the from the CIA I
think though that at the time it led to
the real ascendancy of the FBI encounter
tip account or intelligence in in the
wake of the Ames case the FBI took over
counterintelligence and began to
continually point to the CIA as the
source of more moles and as we now know
they were blind to the fact that the
next mole was actually inside the FBI
and so there's been a cycle I think to
the way in which counterintelligence has
been handled over the last decade one in
which first one agency and then the
other is kind of beset by
finger-pointing and I think what we
tried to do in this book was just kind
of look at it you know in a more
objective and historical fashion but I
mean you've raised a good point because
morale was terrible after the the Ames
case there was a lot of blame to go
around and and but I think today these
the FBI is going through much the same
thing
thank you in the new york times yeah I
was gonna say uh over here two brief
questions please identify Stephen Shore
and with the PBGC a wholly domestic
federal agency our two brief questions
does your book resolve but the story
about your chenko and then there was
something that struck me as curious in
shortly after the coup failed mm-hmm it
was said that then President Bush had
provided Gorbachev with advance warning
that there would be an attempt right
which to me raises two questions that
essentially then President Bush's
sources and methods did he have was his
knowledge based on American penetration
of the KGB and B if so couldn't Gord
Bush wouldn't Gorbachev essentially have
been compromised by relying on American
intelligence sources in his own
decision-making well it's actually gets
to a good point which was that I wanted
to get to we really haven't had a chance
to talk about the whole last part of our
book which is about the 1989 291 time
period between the fall of the Berlin
Wall through the Soviet coup what you're
referring to specifically was actually
not through the CIA the information came
much more openly the mayor of Moscow
went to the American ambassador Jack
Matlock and warned him I think it was in
June of 91 that he believed that there
was a coup forming against Gorbachev a
coup of the hardliners inside the
government
Matlock then went to Baker James Baker
the Secretary of State Baker then held a
quiet meeting with b'smeared Nick the
foreign minister who passed on the
warning to Gorbachev and Gorbachev
dismissed it that was the only as far as
we can tell the only official or
authorized warning from the United
States to the Soviets
the CIA did not have any advance warning
of the coup specifically they did have
some intelligence suggestive that there
was something about to happen
and there were intelligence analysts in
in Langley who were putting things
together just from open sources as much
as anything else looking at the
destabilizing effect that Gorbachev's
policies were having maybe you want to
get into a little bit yeah we we had we
had wonderful source reporting on them
gearing up for something but it looked
in many cases almost slapstick and we
thought well this doesn't mean
something's going to happen tomorrow I'd
let a delegation of CIA people to Moscow
and was there
72 hours before the coup that I can tell
you at the general officer level at most
points that we could touch in the KGB
they didn't know either that this thing
was going to happen at that moment and I
think it happened because somebody
opened the closet and said there's
another case of vodka here and so all
these bozos slugged down just enough and
they said let's go for it and they did
and it just became a horribly slapstick
thing and and all the way through the
eastern there the western group of
forces in East Germany who were supposed
to respond and come riding in and like
the seventh calf and that was a joke
because they're all sitting around
finally given orders to collect bus fare
or something well the most interesting
you should point out the most
interesting piece of intelligence the
CIA got came months earlier when a
Russian source said that Soviet officers
in West in Germany were being asked to
volunteer for special operations in
Moscow it was unclear at that time what
that was for and it's not it's never
been clear as far as I know the owner
whatever had her views were the question
always was asked across the table of
avant Anisa which would Jew fire upon
Russian citizens great Russians to save
the the so uses the Union and everybody
says yeah because you know that's what
the answer was supposed to be but it
turned out to be a almost a cruelly
slapstick affair on the Yurchenko thing
Jim might have I think he has probably
the same sense of it is Gingka was a
different
or he came over he defected and then he
figured he could beat the system when we
we we leaked everything and we we kinda
I think we present this fairly
illustrate in a straightforward way in
the book we kept dropping everything
into the Washington Times and or Bill
Casey did and finally at one point he
said what you're doing to me is you're
trying to do some make make it clear
that I can never go back well I'll show
you and he used a defense that had been
time-honored with KGB defectors they
kidnapped me and drugged me and I
finally kept spitting out my drug until
I was clear-headed enough to get home
and he was brought home and I believe he
was a defector he wasn't sent over as a
starburst type of thing as a distraction
but Jim Mike oh well I I agree with
everything Milt said and but I think
it's it's one of those stories that is
ripe to become a conspiracy theory I
mean how else do you explain the fact
that he gets off the airplane at Andrews
Air Force Base and his debriefer is
Alder James the guy who walked who gets
in the car and drives with him to a safe
house just two months after alder James
had volunteered to the Soviets I mean
you couldn't ask for a better conspiracy
theory than that but I talked to alder
James by letter in prison and he I think
presented me with a fairly convincing
story about this and that is that he
knew this KGB well enough and he
understood I think he was widely
considered inside the CIA at the time as
one of the CIA's experts on the KGB
probably for good reason and he
understood enough about the compartment
ation inside the KGB and understood
where your chinko fit in the structure
of the KGB that he was convinced that
your chinko didn't know about him prior
to him getting off that airplane he also
figured that since your chinko who is a
so he was a full colonel in the KGB he
was about to become a general for those
of you may not remember the case he
defected in August of 1985 in Rome he
entered the US Embassy in Rome and
offered his services while he was there
that first day in Rome he said to the CI
officer David Shore he says there is a
mr. Robert who was a mole in American
intelligence he was a fired CIA officer
who was about to go to Moscow that cable
came back to Washington and everyone
Burton Gerber who was then the division
chief said that's got to be Edward Lee
Howard because he fit the profile of a
fired CI officer Yurchenko came to
Washington and immediately when Ames got
in the car with him
what Ames told me is he passed him a
note saying is there anything you want
to tell only to the Director of Central
Intelligence meaning is there some other
mole something so secret that you don't
want to tell anybody else just tell me
here Aldrich Ames and your chinko looked
at the note and he smiled and said no
but then what Ames told me which was
fascinating which I don't think has ever
come out before he said he said your
chenko then told me a piece of KGB
office gossip which I knew had was
highly relevant to me and in his letter
to me where he described that he didn't
tell me what that highly relevant office
gossip was but I have to assume because
of other things I've heard that it
related to the fact that the KGB
rezident in Washington had returned
suddenly to Moscow a month or two
earlier in the spring and everyone in
the KGB figured something was up in
Washington a name said that what he did
was very bureaucratically astute he took
that piece of information and put it in
his debriefing report where he knew no
one would read it Thank You ambassador
Carter just two small footnotes first I
think you've got the Yurchenko story
certainly very well the information from
Popov about the coup was given to the
American ambassador in order to be
relayed to Yeltsin who was that time in
the United States and the I'm not sure
whether
when you got a burr trough was sold
about it he was told that this had been
given by Popoff the mayor to be relayed
to Yeltsin but that may have put a
special spin on it as far as the garbage
office was concerned although I think
the main thing is simply that he was
just overconfident in his judgment of
these people and thought that he could
manage things as he had the open attempt
just before that to to give special
powers to the prime minister and so on
also just note as the book does that
those Soviet officers in Germany who had
been sounded out on the possibility of
being available for recall for special
duty and so forth
none of them ever heard anything at the
time of the coup no attempt was made to
follow through and draw on that curious
attempted recruitment for possible use
and so on thank you for the questions
comments yes
Eugene Foley Foley of associates
probably I decided to preview the book
but is there any reason to believe that
Windham Kobe died mysteriously or was
the story as presented I just think his
canoe turned over but I I can't imagine
how Kobe could turn over and I can do
and ever have anybody believe it I think
you know John I mean I think just bill
Kobe had wasn't feeling too good that
day and then when I was canoe and that
was the story but I have no idea this
become my purview but the New York Times
has got that one figured out thank you
Jim oh well I think that's right yes
right here we're all pretty no I just
have a process question and that is
there are these books are usually
written in two forms either an agency
former employee writes it and then gets
publication review when it comes out or
an outside writer talks to agency
employees and writes things that don't
get publication with you and frequently
there are a lot of things that are
talked out of school or whatever else
how did you handle this in this
particular case because you know you're
kind of crossing the line in between
those two cases what had to go into the
publication review and what did not well
that was that was the hardest part of
the whole process was Milton I just
talked that through constantly it was
like adding another layer of editing
really to the whole process and took a
lot of discipline I think but I think it
was an experiment we wanted we knew no
one else had ever done this before
and as Milt said at the beginning we
wanted to try and get an insider feel
but also have a kind of an outsider
broader lens to it and so what we did
was we just would go line by line
through the book as we wrote you know
separating out what could go to PRB and
what could not we you know interviewed
people separately so it was it was a
very conscientious effort on our part to
we always had to be aware of this you
know the the one thing Jim just kind of
was a throwaway line
we never did joint interviews of anybody
so and Jim would spend hours and hours
with both Russian and American sources
they understood the American CIA
officers understood that Jim was not
submitting any of his stuff it has been
done in the past there was one book
written by someone in the media on CIA
where he was given access and he had it
would go through the review process but
they knew this in advance and they knew
when I was talking to them that it would
go through a review process in fact I
think you'll read the book you'll see
that the third layer of discipline
probably has has made it work but that's
difficult to do but the remarkable thing
is we got through three years of this
and you know I don't think Jim's my
favorite New York Times guy after this
weekend ambassador guardhouse yes I'd
like to make a comment that point
CIA declassification has had ups and
downs particularly when it comes to the
question of of releasing files documents
and so on but I think it should be noted
that in the last several years they the
agency has very much opened up on what
it is prepared to clear as far as
materials of former CIA officers just a
few years ago
officers particularly from the
clandestine services would find it very
difficult to say almost anything about
actual operational working about their
careers and and the books were for that
part very thin but in the last several
years although there is this process of
review and they certainly look at very
small specific details and so on
carefully but the general process is now
much much more open than one might
expect or then was the case before with
respect to permitting retired and former
officers to to tell a great deal based
on their own histories and experience
and so on thank you yes in the corner al
Millican washington independent writers
since the final showdown has there been
an opportunity for real friendship or
bonding to take place between former CIA
and former KGB agents that's a good
question
I don't think so I think in in in the in
the true sense of the word I think that
I have spent I'll answer this mainly
because I'm the former CIA guy and we
spent days with the the former KGB I
think we reached a real accommodation
and in one case with with the guy that's
through the whole book rim sir gave its
krasilnikov I felt a certain sense of
affection but but the bonding thing they
were there was always something that was
going to prevent that from ever
happening and nor did either one of us
really expect it to but certainly and he
just died last month which will go into
the next edition of this
it wasn't like possibly to rather use
the other analogy you know world war one
fighter pilots saying oh we're all in
the same business you know they're
really who never was a moral equivalency
there and and that would always I think
get in the way of things the Soviet
Union by its own count carried out you
know maybe 40 million wrongful deaths of
its own citizens and if you if you'd
look at the United States during the
period in nineteen seventeen to nineteen
ninety one the same period you'd be
hard-pressed even the historians to say
who has suffered wrongful death at the
hands of its government people will say
oh Sacco Vanzetti or the Kent's eight
kids when oh no probably in the house I
mean somebody could maybe come up with
one but I don't so with you know we
never quite did that there was always
something that we were the shirts and
they were the skins and it never was
going to get really beyond that Thank
You ambassador car drove Soviet
intelligence officers and former
military officers and Foreign Service
officers and so have now participated in
quite a number of the international
conferences on different aspects of the
Cold War and so forth and they were
prepared to sit down with Western former
counterparts if you wish or opposite
numbers and historians and others and
more or less some more and some less get
into the spirit of things and discuss it
what they are not what former Soviet
intelligence officers are not prepared
to do is to sit down in the same table
or the same conference with major
defectors the efforts have been made
and have always failed to get a former
retired KGB officers in good standing to
come to conferences with Gordievsky and
Kalugin and others and this they won't
do I can tell you one one thing from my
own experience of interviewing one
former KGB officer victor chu kashun who
is chief of counterintelligence in the
washington rezidentura in 1985 when all
of the year of the spy was going on he
was willing to talk to me a great length
of a few years ago about Aldrich Ames
who would by that time had already been
arrested and but what I didn't realize
at the time I was interviewing when I
thought he was being so expansive was
that he was also the man who had been
Robert Hansen's handler and I had no
idea at the time I was interviewing him
and I thought he was being so
cooperative that he had this other
secret that he was still keeping thank
you I think we're running out of time we
just a couple more minutes left last
question over here and then I apologize
there will be some time hopefully
afterwards to talk in person to the
co-authors and commentators the last
question
cliff Hackett Jean Monnet counsel I
don't know if this is better addressed
to a Raymond Garth Hoff or to Bearden
but if the PR B's attitude in recent
years has loosened up has become more
liberal does that mean that before that
liberalization that this book might have
been put under a restriction so that
they would not have given Milt released
to publish unless they also saw what
James Rosen had written it's a good
question I don't know my bet my bet is
that they'd be reluctance really so
close in to the first amendment I think
that most of the people engaged in
publication review at CIA know that the
300-pound gorilla in the room
nobody likes to talk about the First
Amendment I don't think they'd ever want
to touch that unless Jim had gone to
them and said here's my deal let me have
some access to files and I'll let you
look at my stuff and and we didn't want
any of that Jim didn't want any of that
we wanted to do it exactly the way we
did in an earlier time I mean maybe but
I mean look I mean this is some you know
the United States and you couldn't do
this book in the UK I mean I can't
imagine that you could do this almost
anywhere else I think the history it was
you know that since this was historical
also I think the fact that this was a no
one had really done a comprehensive
history of Cold War intelligence and I
think that made a difference the fact
that it was a history rather than
current events I would not have tried to
do something that was current so so I
think that made a difference I think
also that there's a number of I've
thought about this a lot there's a lot
of different ways to try and find out
classified history classified historical
information a number of other authors
have done at different ways I think Milt
mentioned Evan Thomas I think when he
wrote the very best men gained access to
CIA files under an agreement with the
CIA and under which the information he
obtained from those files was subject to
clearance and that was a different
approach than one that I did I thought
this was better for him I for me did not
have anything I do go under any CIA
clearance thank you there's clearly a
lot more in the main enemy that we could
have talked about today our time
unfortunately is limited let me thank
our four panelists for insightful
presentations and commentaries I think
they stimulated a good initial abate
about the book thank you for coming
thank you for being here and sharing
your insights and I hope to see you
again at a future Cold War project
seminar thank you
the main enemy the inside story of the
CIA's final showdown with the KGB is
published by Random House on the web at
Random House dot-com